Non, mais moi depuis le début,
cette planète, je la sens pas.
Bonjour!
J’espère que vous êtes venus avec des idées d'animaux parce que
(...)
là, on n'est pas très bien
parce que la boss, elle a pas trop appréciée nos dernières propales.
- Elle a pas aimé les dinosaures?
- Non, non, elle a pas aimé,
d'ailleurs, elle a envoyé une météorite, il reste plus rien.
- QUOI?? (en chœur)
- Et mon T-Rex? Elle a pas gardé mon T-Rex??
Noon, non non non. Il y a, il y a plus rien.
Bref, il faut tout repeupler, donc on a beaucoup de boulot.
Euh, je vous écoute hein..
Ouais, ouais. J'avais pensé à un animal : le ph.., le phas..me, le phasme
D'accord, on s'est peut-être pas compris. En fait, c'est la réunion pour les animaux,
les végétaux, on est bon.
- Ah non, mais c'est un animal. Ça..ça bouge un peu.
- Super! Donc, on commence avec une branche qui bouge.
- (Elle va kiffer) Ok. Moi, j'ai l'araignée,
ça a 8 pattes velues, ça fait des toiles collantes pour attraper ses proies
et ça peut pondre des œufs sous la peau.
- Sous la peau??
Ohhh nan.. (en groupe)
- Ah non. Mais à chaque fois, toi, c'est dégueulasse
Chef! J'ai une propale énorme. Vous allez adorer.
3m de haut, des oreilles comme ÇA , une trompe. En veux-tu, en voilà.
L'éléphant, 6 TONNES!!!
- Alors depuis le début des réunions,
euh
tu fais des animaux qui sont beaucoup trop grands
fais plus petit.
Moi, par exemple, j'ai le chien.
- Oh, c'est bien ça, le chien.
Ça renifle le cul, super sympa.
Ça peut pondre des œufs sous la peau?
Non.
Nan ? Hmmmhm
hrrnnn, hrnnn.
Euh, ouais.
Euh le....le
Le chien de prairie
(rire)
D'accord, donc t'as rien bossé, en fait...
Si, si, carrément.
Euh non, non, alors attendez.
c'est con parce que là j'ai pas le proto. (Il a rien bossé du tout)
C'est différent, c'est un peu plus profilé.
OK.
La mante religieuse.
C'est frais comme ça, hein?
Elle mange la tête du mâle pendant l'accouplement.
Ohh ! (putain)
C'est nutritif, la tête du mâle.
Moi, j'ai un truc vous allez kiffer, c'est énorme, hein.
Grosse crinière, majestueux, des dents affutées pour dévorer sa proie.
Le koala. (avec une petite voix)
Moi, j'avais un animal super mignon, vraiment inoffensif.
Ça mange des feuilles, euh, j'avais pensé l'appeler :
Le LION ! (voix agressive)
On va peut-être inverser les noms.
Oui ! (Parce que le nom de l'un va bien à l'autre en fait)
Ouais, en le disant, je me suis rendu compte. (hein ?!)
Ah oui, sinon, j'ai la sangsue et....
..non...c'est dégueulasse... c'est sur c'est dégueulasse...
Mais non, mais pas du tout...
Ça se ventouse à sa victime avec ses dents pour boire le sang et.. ah oui...
(oui c'est dégeulasse..)
Imaginez, un mammifère sous-marin de 30 mètres de long !
LA BALEINE !
30 MÈTRES !?
30 mètres, qu'est-ce que c'est 30 mètres ?
30 mètres, c'est la taille d'un immeuble !
On fait pas..on l'a dit à la dernière réunion,
ON NE FAIT PAS DES ANIMAUX DE LA TAILLE D'UN IMMEUBLE ! (en chœur)
Ouais.
Euh ouai, le.....le poisson-chat.
pfff (rires)
D'accord, donc là, carrément, on travaille plus, quoi !
On prend 2 animaux on en fait un 3ème..
C'est ça l'idée.. ces't..
Chef ?! J'ai plus petit.
L'ornithorynque.
Et bah voilà ! Tu vois quand tu peux, c'est bien ça l'ornith...le nom est bizarre mais j'adore.
Heu mais attend, tu m'as volé ma fiche, c'est un castor-canard, c'est à moi ça.
C'est un ornithorynque. (c'est un ornithorynque)
Le dodo !
C'est comme un gros pigeon, un peu..
euh, ça vole pas, par contre.
Bah, à quoi ça sert si ça vole pas ?
Si ça vole pas...autant garder le pigeon, quoi !
Oh non, mais s'il-vous-plaît là !
Venez ! On m'en valide au moins un, moi j'adore celui-là, en plus !
On n'en met que quelques-uns si vous voulez !
Ok, on en met quelques-uns en beta-testing quelques part. (Yes !)
..On mettra que des mâles...
Alors moi j'ai...
..non, non, non !..
Si c'est un animal dégueulasse qui pond des œufs sous la peau, tu dégages.
(Oh non...)
Ok bon, je vais bosser dessus..
On revient... On revient de...j'passe mon tour.
Bon moi, j'ai un truc, ça va vous plaire !
Le cheval !
Oh ! Efficace !
Et j'ai même un slogan :
"Le cheval, c'est trop, génial !"
Ça rime en plus..
C'est marrant chef parce que moi, j'ai eu exactement
la même idée que vous, comme quoi, les grand esprits se rencontrent.
Avec un COU DE 3 MÈTRES !
Pfouuu..
C'est quoi ton problème avec les tailles !?
J'avais pensé à des animaux
avec des capacités
J'ai un mulot jaune...
Pikachu ! Il fait des éclairs.
Des animaux avec des capacités c'est ça !?
(ouais !)
Non ! Non, non, on y croit pas du tout...
Nan mais c'est con
parce que j'en avais 150 des comme ça..
Le serpent !
Il manque les pattes !
Les pattes ?! Non.. non, non, c'est fait exprès..
C'est voulu ça..
J'ai pas mis de pattes
Mais.. comment il se déplace si
Il a pas de pattes..
Et bah..y..sur le sol..comme ça..
y..comment on dis...y..
Il coulisse !?
Sur le sol..
Et..il avance..et..il a du venin..
à l'intérieur qui tue immédiatement ses victimes..
Rhôoo..
Tu..tu sais quoi !?
Tous tes animaux..
On va les mettre dans un même endroit
Dans une île juste pour toi..
Qu'on va appeler..
L'Au..
Stra !?...
Lie !
L'Australie, voilà !
Tu mets tous ce que tu veux
Bah merci !.. Bah du coup..
Attendez parce que j'avais aussi le scorpion
Il a un grand pic, acéré.
Mets-en plein !
OH oh !!
Ah oui !
Le ver !
De ?
Terre...
Le ver de terre.
D'accord mais là
Carrément il manque la tête
Où est la tête ?
Ah oui alors ça, je me suis permis, c'est une petite fantaisie
Euh..
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas hyper précis
C'est un peu où l'on veut, la tête.
Ça, c'est un animal qu'est assez polyvalent.
Ce mec n'a rien bossé.
Moi, j'ai un animal avec des pics
acérés dans le dos
pour BIEN SE DÉFENDRE EN CAS D'AGRESSIONS!
Trop violent, arrête !
Mais non, mais ça tient dans la main !
C'est trop mignon !
Le hérisson !
Oh c'est mignon !
C'est super mignon! Bah, bien sûr que c'est mignon !
Vous me faites jamais confiance !!
Elle a raison. (ok)
Euh..euh..Ah oui, voilà !
Ça, alors ça !
Ça, je pense, c'est validé d'avance..
Non !
Ok.
Dans le genre tout mignon, super mimi..
Alors là, regarde..
Le Gremlin, alors !!??
Le Gremlin, non ?
Super mimi ! (hein !!)
C'est mimi, c'est mignon..
On va en mettre plein partout...
Attends..tends...tends...
Il fait quoi ton Gremlin, exactement ???
Rien...Il fait pas de..
Rien de particulier....
Ok...
Faut pas le nourrir après minuit,
sinon il se transforme en ça.
Ah !!!!
Mais non...
C'est ignoble...
Ah ok ! J'ai !
NAN ! (en chœur)
Attendez, j'ai pas encore...
Non, ça c'est génial...
Non...
Bah non (toujours pas...)
Allez, on enchaîne, d'autres...
Euh...
Alors moi j'ai...j'ai...
Ouais....
Bah euh...
Moi j'ai..j'ai tout niqué
J'ai tout..j'ai tout donné...
Comment, vous avez plus rien !? plus rien !?
Ça, on n'avait pas...
Non ! Non !
Je vais pas terminer là-dessus, c'est pas possible..
Un dernier, un dernier !
Un truc catchi quoi !
N'importe quoi !
Bah si, on avait ce...
On avait ce truc, on avait travaillé mais..
On n'était pas sûr..
Ouais, mais c'est pas fini, c'est pas ....
Non...c'est pas abouti...
Dites..dites toujours !
Comment ça s'appelle?
L'Homme...
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Ça mesure 10 mètres ?
Ca pèse 6 tonnes ?
Non.....
Non, ça explore, ça construit des trucs...
Bah, c'est super ça !
Le.. Homme !
Non, mais franchement là, on tient un bon truc !
Là, vous avez fait fort !
Bah, ça se tue entre eux...
Explore.. c'est super ! L'Ho-mme.
Eh, la bosse, elle va kiffer!
Non franchement, vous êtes bons là !
On va en mettre partout !
Bon bah pause déj' ?
Ouais, hein, allez! (rire)
ALLEZ !
Merci à toute et a tous pour votre visionnage bande de kikoo.                              Cyprien Iov